je sais pas
vous mais moi quand j'étais petit
j'avais envie de tout comprendre
j'aimerais juste tout savoir et je
voulais savent
je sais avoir demandé aux grands mais
pourquoi il si elle est bleu bleu on m'a
jamais répondu
pourquoi quand on laisse tomber une
fourmi elle se fait pas mal pourquoi en
fait d'où vient la poussière pourquoi
y'a des choses mouillé et il ya des
choses pas mouillé et en fait je me suis
naturellement dirigés vers la science
vers une formation de scientifiques et
vous savez comment c'est d'année en
année au fil du temps mais j'ai choisi
les une spécialité et puis une autre et
puis j'ai atterri en thèse et j'ai fait
une thèse sur le comportement des
fourmis je suis aussi éthologue il doit
y en avoir deux dans la fal et donc
c'était une thèse sur l'écologie des
fourmis et la relation avec les arbres
et les plantes et je me suis retrouvé à
faire des colloques internationaux sur
les insectes sociaux est ma spécialité
donc c'est les fourmis on était
peut-être 800 à washington sur les
insectes sociaux et dans le séminaire de
ma thèse et main il y avait douze
personnes peut-être 12 15 personnes au
monde qui comprenait ce que je faisais
qu'ils aient changé
et voilà moi j'ai appris avec ses cinq
années de thèse
j'ai un peu lent cinq années pour moi
c'était assez dur parce que j'ai
découvert d'abord d'une part qui avait
des personnes qui adorent et faire les
choses à fond
il faut un tout petit sujet le fond à
fond à fond à fond
voire peut-être toute leur vie ils
adorent aller au fond des choses
ces gens là je les appelle les à fonds
distincts il y en a plein je les admire
puisque j'ai plutôt la tendance inverse
celle de me disperser
et j'adore butiner d'une discipline
scientifique à l'autre d'un sujet à
l'autre comme une abeille
qui du tyne voilà sur plein de fleurs
différentes et j'ai remarqué au fil du
temps il y avait des personnes comme moi
je les appelle les dix persistent et la
thèse c'est l'exercice à fond dit par
excellence le problème c'est que moi je
n'étais pas à l'aise là dedans j'ai
quand même fini
et alors le ski est donc l'institution
de la science ne permet pas assez en
tout cas aujourd'hui de de déployer
c'est le sait c'est capacité 10 persiste
des gens et en fait ce qui est truculent
disons c'est que à la fin de ma thèse ma
directrice de thèse qui a passé son
temps finalement à me recadrer elle me
l'a dit à la fin eh bien on m'a donné un
diplôme et elle était très fière parce
que moi j'avais fait une une thèse sur
comment les fourmis prennent les graines
des plants en échange d'un peu de
nourriture et vont les mettre à la bonne
place les disperse et donc j'ai été
nommée elle m'a dit je suis fier de te
domaine docteur en dispersion j'ai enfin
pu m'épanouir me décomplexer
enfin je vais pouvoir faire ce que je
fais ce que je veux c'est à dire aller
butiner d'une fleur à l'autre et donc je
suis sorti du milieu académique qui
c'était en 2008 et j'ai fait de
l'éducation populaire dans une
association en belgique pendant quelques
années
pendant quatre ans j'ai fait des
articles des conférences nous avons fait
en équipe des débats des ateliers sur
tout ce qu'on voulait c'est assez
magnifique on a été dans les sciences
dans la politique le militantisme y
avait le féminisme l'écologie sociale et
solidaire et enfin j'ai pu déployer la
philosophie et c'est pour moi j'avais un
passé scientifique et et un goût aussi
pour la science donc j'ai j'ai vite été
sur les thématiques de l'état de notre
monde et du système terre et de notre
planète
et alors là j'ai découvert plein de
choses alors j'ai comme j'ai été voir en
climatologie
c'est catastrophique
mais si vous prenez un climatologue qui
a un esprit un peu disons cloisonné dans
sa discipline ou un esprit d'ingénieurs
je peux me moquer un peu des ingénieurs
parce que je suis aussi ingénieur et
bien demandez lui à l'ingénieur de
trouver une solution
eh bien il va dire non pourrait faire de
la géo-ingénierie on va répandre des
produits dans le ciel qui vont faire
pleuvoir
c'est une bonne idée ça mais en fait
sans se rendre compte que ça peut amener
des problèmes de pollution de problèmes
de de ressources comment on fait en
énergie ou en ressources rares peut-être
pour pour produire ça ou même
géopolitique
si un pays est capable de faire de la
pluie c'est une arme ou des tempêtes
c'est une arme de destruction massive
et c est en fait souvent on invite dans
les débats à la télé ou en sciences une
personne un spécialiste pour parler d'un
problème mais si on invite à côté un
spécialiste de du pétrole on va dire le
pétrole en aura on en a beaucoup
actuellement on en extrait beaucoup mais
à un moment on en aura plus le pic de
pétrole conventionnel c'est à dire le
moment où l'extraction commence à
diminuer et 4 le conventionnel c'est le
liquide le voilà le le pétrole le 80% du
pétrole c'est du brut conventionnel est
en fait il le pic a été passé en 2006
donc vous appelez un ingénieur et vous
dit et vous lui dites trouvez moi une
solution pour le pétrole conventionnel
et ben il faut aller vers les pétroles
de schiste et gaz de schiste peut-être
même les sables bitumineux
les hydrates de méthane et c est alors
vous inviter le climatologue vie non ça
c'est pas compatible en fait si vous
invitez ces deux personnes là leurs
solutions ne sont pas compatibles pas
tout en tout cas et si vous invitez un
financier en économistes un politicien
un spécial écologue spécialistes de la
biodiversité
quelqu un spécialiste des problèmes de
l'eau et vous les mettez tous autour de
la table
finalement vous aurez un une image
globale assez différentes de chaque
détail c'est comme moi je suis allé un
petit peu voir j'ai la capacité d'aller
voir dans toutes ces disciplines mais je
suis pas spécialiste je peux pas aller
dans le détail au pinceau fin au laser
par contre je peux tracé des pointillés
et finalement on a un tableau
impressionniste on peut voir globalement
ce qui se passe ils ont le tableau
global et cette démarche on a fait avec
raphaël stevens un ami en belgique sur
justement les effondrements les
catastrophes globale et cette vision
systémique nous a montré que en fait les
risques et les menaces de chaque
discipline sont graves mais quand on
voit l'ensemble c'est beaucoup plus
grave en fait la somme et plus le tout
est plus que la somme des parties
alors on l'a mis ça dans notre livre
comment tout peut s'effondrer qui montre
justement ce côté systémique des
catastrophes et on a aussi un autre
exemple deux en deux ans plus tard avec
gauthier chapelle un ami biologiste on a
fait un livre qui s'appelle l'entrée de
l'autre loi de la jungle pour aller
découvrir comme toutes les manières
qu'ont les êtres vivants de s'associer
alors moi je fais partie évidemment de
des insectes sociaux ma passion et puis
j'ai découvert d'autres choses sur les
sociétés animales et puis les végétaux
les arbres et champignons les microbes
et bactéries
et puis les humains commencent centraide
et s'associent les humains mais alors
chez les humains était très cloisonné et
les sciences économiques les sciences
psychologiques et science politique la
sociologie l'anthropologie les sciences
cognitives et à chaque fois chaque
discipline bosser dans son dans son pré
carré
il y avait a finalement assez peu de
liens est en fait encore une fois avec
le tableau global et ben on a pu déceler
faire sortir en pointillés disons aux
méthodes pointilliste des principes des
grands principes qui traverse toutes ces
disciplines des principes du vivant est
ce que ce qui est formidable ce qui est
fou c'est que ces principes du vivant eh
ben on les retrouve dans les
associations dans le coaching de
management parce que ces principes si on
les applique dans les groupes des
recettes salées saleh disons que ça
marche beaucoup mieux en permaculture
aussi si on applique ces principes du
vivant ça marche beaucoup mieux la
permaculture c'est ça c'est
l'application des principes du vivant
pour concevoir des systèmes durable
soutenable résilient etc
et en permaculture aussi si vous en avez
fait un peu il ya des principes de
design pur design et concevoir des
systèmes résilient et durable eh bien on
nous dit en design de permaculture j'en
ai fait un peu quand j'étais en
éducation populaire et bien il faut
aller dans le détail et dans global et
quand vous design et faut faire cet
aller-retour détail globales détail
globales il faut les deux s'il manque
l'inde est l'un des points de vue c'est
toujours bancal et donc 7,7
cette pensée systémique décloisonner
c'est ce que font ou enfin c'est ce que
j'appelle où c'est ce qu'on appelle la
pensée horizontale avec gauthier raphaël
par opposition évidemment la pensée
verticale on a besoin des deux
évidemment qu elle l avantage la peau
c'est horrible à penser horizontal et
bien moi j'en vois trois déjà que quand
on a un système on voit l'ensemble du
tableau on peut voir globalement ce qui
se passe on a une autre vision on a des
choses qui émergent qui sont nouvel
ensemble avec la vision d'ensemble
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on peut voir
les liens entre les éléments entre les
disciplines entre les choses et les
liens ça apporte aussi des dynamiques
différentes périodes sur le cas de
l'effondrement
eh bien il ya des effets dominos les
problèmes de biodiversité sont liées aux
problèmes climatiques qui sont liées au
problème des ressources de l'énergie
donc de la politique et de la
géopolitique et c est en fait tout tout
est lié et les risques peuvent
déclencher des effets dominos qui sont
bien plus graves
quand on le voit globalement et il ya un
autre aspect avantage disons clap de la
pensée horizontale c'est la nouveauté
c'est à dire que une discipline qui
trouvent une méthode nouvelle quelque
chose de nouveau
en fait on bonne abeilles
pollinisatrices on peut importer cette
méthode nouvelle et l'amener à une autre
discipline c'est l'intérêt de la
pollinisation
ou de cette pensée horizontale prenez un
cas si vous avez mal au ventre par
exemple mal à l'estomac
vous allez consulter qui vous allez voir
qu'ils le spécialiste mondial de
l'estomac
pourquoi pas ou un nutritionniste ou un
gastro entérologue ou un médecin
généraliste qui va peut-être voir
l'ensemble du cac connaître votre
famille ou un médecin holistique ou qui
fait de la médecine chinoise
ou peut-être vous allez voir quelqu'un
qui va voir vos liens avec votre famille
vos amis
peut-être votre travail travail qui vous
fait mal au ventre où vous passez votre
passé vos ancêtres
peut-être c'est tout peut-être vous avez
besoin de tout en fait peut-être ces
complémentaires et donc on a besoin à la
fois de la pensée horizontale holistique
systémique et de la pensée verticale
réductionniste qui travaille au pinceau
qui va profond etc
on a continué cette démarche de
décloisonnement avec gauthier et raphaël
sur la question de l'effondrement ou des
catastrophes glôglô globale des risques
systémiques majeur et en fait on s'est
rendu compte que juste toutes les
disciplines
même si elles étaient interconnecter les
disciplines scientifiques n'arrivait pas
à prendre la mesure des choses
en fait ça touche et ça c'est une
question qui rend fou le possible
effondrement notre société et sa touche
à des questions émotionnel éthique
métaphysique spirituel etc etc
artistique aussi et donc on a dû se
mouiller on a dû ce passionné on a dû
s'intéresser et faire des liens entre
tous à sortir décloisonner de la science
de la tour d'ivoire est allé voir et
faire des liens entre les personnes qui
sont aussi qu'ils se retrouvent croiser
au nez c'est notre démarche de faire du
lien entre tout ça entre toutes ces ses
postures ses démarches c'est discipline
dans notre livre une autre fin du monde
est possible et ça m'amène
du coup à définir un peu mieux qu'est ce
qu'un chercheur interdépendants alors
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on se définit
avec gauthier et raphaël une petite
boutade parfois pour faire parler les
journalistes
mais c'est surtout pour montrer notre
interdépendance l'interdépendance de
tous toutes les disciplines tous les
gens tout avec notre passé avec notre
futur etc
l'interdépendance de tous
l'interdépendance radical de tous les
êtres c'est le principe de l'écologie de
l'écologie relationnel comme on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure et finalement ça
m'amène au au coeur de mon propos ce
soir de cette conférence là c'est plutôt
de propositions plutôt qu'un propos ces
deux maîtres dans nos vies plus de et de
passer du ou au et et c'est une
proposition qui a une filiation très
longue on peut aller de deux gars morin
à joe hahn a mais ici aux etats unis
récemment ils sont encore vivants mais
ça va jusqu'à héraclite passer du ou et
décloisonner la cdu verticale à
l'horizontale ou en tout cas apporter
plus d'horizontal je vous en ai apporté
quelques uns nature ou culture inné ou
acquis corps ou esprit raison ou
émotions et nature et culture inné et
acquis corps et esprit raison et émotion
souvent on entend dire non mais pour
résoudre les problèmes de la planète
il faut des militants il faut des luttes
non il faut méditer
il faut retrouver un chemin intérieur
vous se changer soi même
est-ce qu'il faut plus de militants ou
de méditant ou
est-ce qu'il faut pas les deux plus de
mes militants et de mehdi temps est ce
qu'on n'a pas su et en nous réconcilier
en nous le midi le militant et le
méditant est-ce qu'il faut des solutions
individuelles ou collectives
mais les deux évidemment si on n'a pas
l'un des deux entrées bûche en boîte
écouter celle là elle et elle est aussi
sympa elle est vicieuse un mail est
marrante
si on sort pas du nucléaire et du
charbon dans les années qui viennent on
aura à la fois la peste et le choléra
je laime beaucoup celle là moi j'ai plus
envie de choisir entre où la lutte ou la
création d'alternative il faut les deux
il faut évidemment les deux
je suis un être catastrophique ce
catastrophiste et joyeux et
universitaires et militants et artistes
et spirituelle et en fait c'est pas des
étiquettes c'est juste ça me ça ne me
définis pas ça montre ce que je suis à
tel moment et ça peut changer
ce ne sont pas des étiquettes ou des
identités moi j'ai envie de fromage et
de desserts de ketchup et de mayonnaise
et je rêve qu'on pense locales et
globales et qu'on agisse locales et
globales et je rêve aussi que notre
société que nous laissions plus de place
à cette pensée horizontale qu'elle se
déploie à la fois en nous dans notre
rapport au monde et dans nos
institutions et surtout scientifique
je rêve qui est plus de haies et vous
vous êtes plutôt ce persiste ou plutôt à
fonds distincts
vous voyez comme le louvre vient
facilement
peut-être qu'on est les deux et ce qui
est génial avec le et c'est qu'il est
radicalement inclusif
parce qu'on a besoin de tout le monde on
a besoin de vous et de et merci